yeah morning everyone no I just like to
go on record to to thank David for
giving me my first chance in coaching
it's something I'll always remember when
he rang me in the in the summer and
asked me to to come on board at
Manchester United obviously I was still
playing but you give me the opportunity
to from a first coaching role secondly I
would like to just say how proud I am to
be managing for the remaining four games
that the club that I've supported all my
life and I've been associated with for
25 26 years so it's a proud moment for
me I'm one that I'll enjoy many times
after answering all questions of the
player what's it like Manchester United
it's good um I've enjoyed the week like
I've just said I'm I'm proud more than
anything it's probably the proudest
moment of my career and one that I'm
going to enjoy for the what
two-and-a-half weeks worth of our
remaining of the season and bring back
some smiles on the faces of the fans and
just look forward to the game just like
just like as a player really it's
prepare yourself as best you can during
the week and look forward to Saturday I
can't wait for for Saturday to come 5:30
norwich at home
I know the stadium we bouncing the the
players look really good in training
this week and they're all excited as
well it's been good it's been good
everyone's looking looking sharp and I
just said to him enjoy yourself
give the fun something to smile about in
these remaining four games because it's
been a frustrating season and we want it
when the season on a high how difficult
the last four days being I mean you've
seen ups and downs at Manchester United
your time here but then it was talk
about your relationship with the
previous manager and all sorts can you
put that into some sort of context right
no it's been a difficult week for the
club obviously it was it was a shock to
me on Tuesday when I spoke to Ed and he
informed me that David was leaving and
then asked me to take over it's just
been a bit of a whirlwind week for me
but let's say one that I've enjoyed and
one as has been different it's been
chaotic and just getting a little taste
I mean it's a fourth day in the job and
it's you can never imagine what you have
to do and the things that have entailed
becoming a Manchester United manager I'm
just concentrating on the short time
that the four games remaining and that's
my that's my main focus my focus is on
Saturday well tomorrow against Norwich
which is going to be a tough game
because they're fighting for the lives
after that not really thought about for
the rest of this season are you still
going to consider yourself as a player
as well as the manager I'll just give
myself a five-year contract
so I'm using my power while I can but no
I yeah I haven't done much this week but
yeah yeah I'm still involved as a player
as well so you don't the attempting to
put yourself in is the first name on the
team she then I've trained okay this
week with a lot of look look look sharp
to be fair so now everyone does look
sharp and there's 20 L players who in
with a chance tomorrow what we look to
change this week in training well just
just try and enjoy yourself and express
yourself I mean I don't know if I'll be
saying that if I was manager last week
because the performance wasn't great but
I've come into the job obviously a my my
media aim is to win Saturday so I felt
the best way to do that is just trying
make training as enjoyable as you can go
out and play and they've done that you
mentioned smiles on faces right you want
to put that back on the fans is it going
to be a different style of play than is
it is it gonna be more as you would kind
of consider a United style of play well
it's gonna be my philosophy it's gonna
be you know obviously munchies you know
its philosophy because I've been here
for all my career and I want the players
to play with passion speed tempo be
brave imagination all the things that I
expect of a Manchester United player
work hard but most of all enjoy it
because as a player if I if I know that
we enjoying the game I can express
myself a lot more and that's what I'll
be doing with the with the team tomorrow
how hurtful has it been to you as a
United fan as you mentioned now you're
so proud to be the United manager for
these games but in terms of the way the
seasons gone and you've had to kind of
you know watch as a player coach book
Canada you know from afar if you like in
many ways as well it's been a
frustrating season I think for everyone
you know you win together and you lose
together and like I say these these four
remaining games I want to bring some
positivity back I want to put smiles on
the faces we've got three home games
that Old Trafford we're a forum hasn't
been great and I want to see goals I
want to see tuples I want to see players
taking players on I want to get the
crowd up and I want one the passion that
should come with being a munchies United
player